loki laupissen i sent it to you to be  reset you ridiculous bureaucrats will  not dictate how my story ends it's not  your story mr laughs and it never was  wren slayer works for the tva  this bureau that really maintains the  integrity of time  anything goes sideways it's on you i  feel like i'm always looking up to you  it's appropriate  she's powerful  she's well respected  she has enormous authority she's someone  that's worked her way up the ranks i  think gugu really captured that journey  why do you get to keep all the trophies  from my cases because i approve the  missions  good point there's a lot of betrayal and  mischief it's really wonderful cheers  i'm excited to watch the show myself